c'est avec soin et minutie que les
conservateurs du musée de la
civilisation en bas les costumes qui ont
marqué l'histoire de la télévision
deux grues jo est délicat aux habits de
la soirée du hockey en passant par les
robes spectaculaires de julie snyder à
l'enfer c'est nous autres
en tout 120 3 costumes chemineront vers
québec
s'ajoutant à une vingtaine d'autres déjà
offert par radio canada
tous ces costumes l'ain seront
entreposés avec toutes les normes et les
soins requis pour la conservation à long
terme le choix des costumes s'est fait
en concertation entre le musée et radio
canada
quand on parle de costumes patrimoniaux
il fallait aussi s'assurer d'avoir toute
la documentation pertinente qui
accompagne chacun de ses costumes est
possible de connaître la valeur
marchande de ces costumes qui seront non
seulement entreposés mais aussi exposé
au musée paul vélo il y aura
certainement un grand événement pour
souligner cette donation à cette grande
nation au musée à la société québécoise
en fait des pourparlers sont en cours
avec un consortium pour déterminer de
l'avenir des 80 mille autres vêtements
du costumier l'important c'est de
conserver l'ensemble de ses vêtements
les non seulement des conserver mes
données rend disponible à l'ensemble de
l'industrie cinématographique et
télévisuelle une page d'histoire se
tourne mais en quittant le costumier ses
vêtements patrimoniaux assure leur
pérennité
ici tanya lapointe radio canada montréal